let's go next to leishan from new york
city lei sean you're on the air
hey david how are you i'm doing good
uh and what ways do you think
uh president joe biden would be superior
or inferior to a president
bernie sanders oh well let's see
inferior would be that biden is to
bernie's uh
right and i am to biden's left
and so i'm closer to bernie than i am to
biden and so from a personal standpoint
i think bernie um would would
of course be a more progressive
president and i would like a more
progressive president than joe biden
in terms of ways in which biden may may
be superior to bernie it really remains
an open question but the argument that's
been made
is biden has the ability
despite not being as progressive to
accomplish more
both because uh of that very same reason
that he's seen as
less of an extreme leftist although
neither bernie nor biden are extreme
leftists in any way
whatsoever and maybe biden's
um historical alliances and
relationships
with the centrist wing of the democratic
party as well as moderate republicans
could allow him to get more done he
won't get things done
that are as progressive as what biden as
what bernie would want to do
but bernie being more progressive if he
can't actually get things done is of of
questionable use
that's the argument right and i'm not
saying it's the right argument but
that's the argument that's being made
and
we'll have four years now to figure it
out
okay uh follow question what big issues
do you think biden is going to
be known for after he's out of office
whether it be infrastructure
foreign policy et cetera first of all
covid
kovetkova donald trump like to say i i
i think that um if joe biden can
navigate
us out of this and we come out of it um
understanding the un unrecoverable
tragedy of the virus but we come out of
it with
not only a stronger economy but
hopefully also
with treatments or vaccinations for
other conditions on the basis of the
rapid advancement of the
mrna technology platform uh and if
if into that we can wrap up a green
infrastructure deal which biden
campaigned on
i think that those have huge potential
to be biden's legacies
and then you know you really never know
right when trump was elected nobody
thought his legacy
one way or the other would depend on a
global pandemic but in huge part it has
so i think it's just too early to say
beyond that
all right uh also how are you liking
discord discord's great
yeah i know i we i love discord
all right david uh great talking to you
all right my pleasure uh great
great to hear from you um okay